and very happy to eye catcher
he must like to tell you about
bias the site
additional problem and it is live 3
overflows in boot
practice and
theory
and tonally heavy hope also in
tell you that these are show you our
after problem and view my  turn into it
in daily practice of zo
i'll tell you about how i use and choir
not that powerful trip to school
dissertation bias en som of ma je kon
the with offering surprice that
this with it and nowhere about any body
if using this with it
no the beatles it so simple what is
you powerful sound inc is true cherry
that before i drive into the top i a
version brief introduction a warm
company hi  joins win house under
senior ziggo and this digital marketing
agency in eindhoven and high five years
ago we ran required by the big tipi
en de week piepie is one of the dinges
media communication and holding globally
wie a  fvalrace the evil large detail
technology that parliament must in green
ice and that's obama has the acquisition
wie already so far the continuous to date and
technology so om or the production be
made within greenhouse sarnami us all
over the world to the door baby pi
network ok  such a completed a company
that stuff in to do the problem so
first of all highlights interpreter and little
bit about determined by lucas in my
opinion is the latest in for very very
many de finds inks
so it might be you build machine
original marie vinck  ok beautiful model the
show of gender bias what is your in that
monastery the more general inspiration s
lanting and just buy it is tweeting
milf strap under the rug
however if i look in the brother
field of expertise with that the order
definitions of buys  if such a baby in
statistics curators built bias test and
food which is more like the estimator the
expectation overestimate there is a the
same thing is the expiration of puppy
try to  eristen would this is normally not
really something that you can't write
and also look into cold al in french
than the f could catch buyers
which basically means
what computing' is a correlation
what is an al die goal so effects on your
band for computer  and then and the top
left corner
theres this machine learning engineer
dat c blue eyed rondo brave badia
sober rita bias lucas bias is your gloomy
warm terry my bias him already would this
is of course complete dvd do know who
came up with the term by grace  and bias is
what i think is who keeps video ban so
hefty percentage
off like to use my own this definition
and it will not help explain what
one girl bias is so the definition al
youth market perspective is
bias is when extra computing' santing
this point  are you a tent to do that it
can be helpful framework fill'd
built in lot of thief a touch up guys
there are already nice writer selectivity bias
it what banking bias edited by so this
money de finds pl  aats bij de tank in
journal good boy de vinken barre this
new york computing something dare and
domien tent
so under the top me or attenuation
basis still works
yes ok so de steak the very simple
example of a linear regression
so what you  want to compute in a
linear
regression the bita
formulates like a fork the camping
surfer just like what you want to do is the
bita for you tricks that's what you're
interested in
however in beatit you were not measuring
your
serving you to ex dan  is time york on
serving and noisy ex
so sweet you through a normal
damien regression
in fact pleasure computing' your pietenhuis
for the toe ex
what you computing computing young bi time
for you noisy x and f you truly in the
setting family defect new york of  fish
and for the 2x than us by is
zo
you can people in the nt ww symbolic
growth by manager of agree so is also
referred to as measurement air and
progression
de loesje
ok zo lets make a very simple
ik simple z  o becomes import and
here I recognize him point
that is there are antonius at my middle
school sec my ex and we slid to
ex bad and who
surfs make-up ex whites coloring sum
goals your savior never knows skill just
with the sigmatex  wat however if i aim ar
linear regression
then i only can use the op surft ex en
op de toe ex
de to access the effect op is
fulfilled so look at the
so
milo's the feel again with biscuit
bobby car but most is arbiter
de  piar looking for curb at five with
davy checkka kon van so interval over
test met bans arie can see the two
point five is very well very far out
site over kon van is interval zo this is
now but you intend to write would you
computing' sometimes  independent and to do
she this is still on someone this is worth a
party is
ok so interviewer is it a party
myers
de mark the noise in your op surf ex
wat wat je extra care about is what
happens my de true exchanges
and there something  import  tant note is
the oil matters of you do in friens
that is not really matter when you
oh don't claim prediction of
forecasting
such
the inglés ebro and so do a small
production to forecasting by my
experience or a project tardis on for
dictionnaire forecasting  problem but
once they apply to business intern would
the boy in french problem at all and
to show their small story that harland
and share what you
sit against baby that the laptop and click
form
that does this for nothing light
rays and stories at the manager and  the
dating scientist and
yes so manager
with his new ones those hard details and the
manager sc
ok 8 is amazing to that
you can
click nothing
you can images middleton looks sales in
these are even a payment thank you
will use this model how will this
creates business  value and then the
manager
is well it was a metaphor after long
your continents so put on a model will
be very very valuable and to
date ok start images in the
predictive models
and then to man slater the this site is
test is super a megging prolific
mobile and very run dictionnaire
en and solid managers 6 oh well let's
see what happens from rechange price so
weekend intermède to give discount and
this is expression of small he are  wolf
ok what starchaser production problem
you can them in french problem of europe
light and business and attending this is
quite often the case
ok so blond lingerie linear models
in general
that is not a be a linear
means for any reason i want to know  how my
changes find toe exchanges you be your
effort a lot of market
and then there's
the relation to carbonic acid in france is
that i say loves a thing with if you
think about carbonic acid in french what you guys
do is ok who maize on surf
what happens  to buy with historics we de
mighty santing fill in the french tv
my sex two vidoe ex die
effects my my big infant so sweet your
working on a cozy and fans problem is
a pay  the strong relationship pray a
girl bias then dc it's a relationship
in not in think about okay be
poor on serving the noisy x value sit
bam influencing bid 2x
so en vesten mind and it's important
ben do grain in friends set built in
at tms bias
so
reasons why i think it innovation by is
s Binnen overlooked wonen is of course
beagles of older great breaks intoxication in
machine learning is Binnenhof focus on
who the production and classification
problem and then very happy to see this
change messeigneurs control zo in french
revolution  badass en narsingh
is a dan if i enjoy the ymea most beautiful
after a week doing conservatism who is search
in rejecting the new hot pot is en
this one shot explainer ditmar carfry
glass dog in specialbite intégration
bias for the a nation by free
download direction of the  buyer is to
most warsaw
so were we have negative or positive
effect is to oh hi smaller than
hobby knife so what is means pig die
myra is
epifanes significant effect
a jury jack is still abortion and who
do not count for it nation bias
who asscher just disinfect
mission bias incitement your vote it
is our ok to reject and her polders is
tough it still to write
however if i account  foundation bias in
the residential area xlii the mobile s noise and
side rex order but no no pay and inositol
an ex
then be my feed cheeks well conclusion would
them i might be thinking of their
effect that it is a military
reality in the fitting of my  academia
perspective of you will i would be
careful about age acting session still
abortion is it nixons note to really
care form that a girl is me just
for their practice and restoration can be
just esbats about estimation and dogs and
model some time alex plans in
detail that's too great
so chemical account for theoretical
basis this family or neat the de mingo
jersey antonino business regression dead
oil square in this liken of family o  f
with the star arm had to so one
and and there are new school or a
refer to srm variables these including the
bagian versions
toolcraft loss and elson recent
developments in training such as a
deep learning in my experience you need
be quite careful with models thick als
he already has such a december rectory where you
can edit our of those slides there are also
sure you
release this model specifications and
put to whether you actually get floor
and by free will and this is want something wiki
of course pickles infiniti that tear
at the getting by jury will in
non-military
meets conclusions
and den ersten solution de be used
without which are explained see you
later to match a guy who just scooter
this is specifically for binary treatment
it is and who leo tease me off without
mumbai  treatment
ok zo let's take a look at how week en
account for this and against nation bias zo
in stad models the first we a
package to account for the nation bias
zo ui  ting so kan an indication that is
over look right but inside out die has
the old yar har torino distance for
fashion package with you can use to
solve the scoan of problems
zo Ook toxic saitek ja zo basically the
work like they should pay for real daten
action by insight de pathologist fashion
and juliet en by swizzle thinking
however that something really important
is that when you did so fresh en je mee
consumption and that song by xlite
die assumption mm dat de sigma ex a
ask me why so the amount of nog  once in
excel my is so one
and so that is a knife oil so the be the
case white and this is such a thing to
important to think about if you account
for decoration bias je niet nl at least
santing building de noise and white noise
in hex
order read issue the read shop between
the faith the adobe much you can solve a
problem and cash on a disco level
effie
doe have an eagles i well weiss i me
exocet mais syrup live here and two'
pass it into your aud  io packers mia
buyers bills a game student see
below je
so love you soft is in jews were
package
my ex light is you can in your wheel deta
objects your child pest york sigmax in a
sector war and if you provided as you
can see you  have combined exchanges I him
so in
short dory member if you want a
confirmation by you do not see to know
something about drama day again in
every extra bite
zo onto the application you experience
so direct hermens
ar used to people die effects knife or
fork simple et  content web context
such as an alternative to abbey testo
randomized controlled trial and
so for reasons why you wanted uji expert
hermens if you're not able to the test
anyway man is the outcome know on die
madge it in tweet mouth featured
groups would fox ampel  if you want to
measure the effect of mobile banners
in in-store sales the week and the week and
do no test it with a mobile
phone who is 7 seasons a barbie with
week and whether the major is it  collapses
phil
this is coincidence desko becky and textile is
an interesting paper
to my colleagues who contributed to
riches do sets studiowit offline and
online
and who is a tool is pas more reason is
something in posible to measure the calls
fleet it comes out and this is fox  handful of
the case in google search such a google it
so parents their work if your advertising
burn out to measure
something about the outcome of the cats
we would be the one to test border is
distress advertising in the fur distress
advertising born at all out to  measure
what is users images from ask a little
bit more specific in to buy you want to
researcher experiment with die fact
from google search youth the p set
access to and the organic at necarbo
and for the also petacchi you not when
this in a box  and once you click them and
you pay for the jet
however moby can measure is where one that
click free get then at the people go to
the website and maybe your purchase
however not necessarily all those muscles
so did the die opt to
so we don't have a think about ok if i
would not have been advertising lord may
be those users must be silent coteaux de
website and also the purchase this can
food problem 1e dood hoor organic
weer Zwartjes bilo de p sets it can
also  be that they just navigate to the
website and sells in t kennels van in
ten boer' voor olielozenen
de purchase is coming van de
Klik omnipage number about estimating the
effectiveness of google apps in this
mobile bank I als number wasting die
het voor 1000 money and  take too much
for nice and on the other hand you
would do anything if bantu underestimate the
effectiveness guild and you might be
getting to know you're not shown and
people might not be able to find your
website to your purchase
zo over smash en adjusters  bed is an
estimation and that's why we need to
account for the echie mission by is
to keep such a google papers building there
germas bork she admit that die level man
united states shifted  is ik no the market
arias marketing arias and dashboard e
split such your random assignment and
cost regions in the netherlands free
most of te use provinces and they gio
level and then there are marlies in google
peper 2017 and third in do people never
too  still regression that you can sit
what is the slide possibly a so
elizabeth i am a very nice get through
the eyes only after seasonality types of
cancer although the papers and greater
then it comes this direction you choose the
unwise account for it a beast corn
in 433 views per mens en de tank de
solution that be used paddy power or not
you can be supplied even be barnum in
treatment
ok so what is the detail look like to
very simple gamble this is too few deed
appoint for actually doing destination
watch time  period en in uw gios we
this procession die birds and to the albert
it is normal more time period or more
gio
and then in the second time period
you can see that treatment
schekelweg
freelance is b  ang voor bang of ten gios
the lid i we die sitecom number they
can about that calculate okay what mighty
effect of the treatment and be
door so then the sanction a set make
it makes it show model
zo lets go to was the solution
so
high first thing  with you think about
her by exactly
you do not a confirmation bias parents
never become an ex we that is never an
ex ex clinic anyway more beautiful in ex
is knuckleheads be measured
does the
most popular gio
we have someone an eye is the effect
of the treatment  show at cs no andy's
review arm i check you guys there is
a chance for an experiment they
may be choir members that did not exactly
variegated band is one and wangi are in
speckles dave and technological
within it used to measure location
sophia in side story the location  but
that had noisy may give your die us eps
in your google search on your phone or if
you is a website that phonetics and dr
noisy anyway though charlie is correctly
built in which you in the region  year
the second reason is jaron the test peri
peri jet people can move shape of that
location die other zo congo of tweeted
and om fries it is not who left you like and
jack who are to know that the
people moving region starlight half
retweeters  nonsense you wouldn't there
account for the scarf by attenuation
bias the courses again desire x
ok torsten solution
would it be so who are those simple powerful
signs they the oil was banned
the cattle point c can think about what if
you laugh and by a  variable so that she has
her cheek and what is it nineve barre
ferrol
is noisy
an extreme move so there are bernoulli
distribution and the bernoulli
distribution and are like papa it is you
so whether you name the video my program
from viewer die distribution and
then  i also know your de the variance
girls here pee
times for my people the spring versus as a
corollary
if you know something about the noise and
witch met you always will forklift if
otherwise you can not a conf  rontation
bar is it all you can absolutely u again
version channel is
calculate pi so simple couple departure is
instead of using your hun bang in her
detail minutes yay for the liter
demon in twitter gios so much bigger
details and politician here what their looks
like so  a star of having zero and when
the gets europoint 15 in such a point in
the time period when there was no
treatment talk about silent zero
what in the time period
wwf who has it are free are you can
see there will be the bus  or crossover
between regions would never be a
theoretical like the second part 1 bit and
the tweeted creatures that arm not fully
tweeter te de lutte this lesson so use
typically set or
sherwood
ok so effie bigger neck slice
you pray or intuition thinking
died old you
the public in singapore is okay who
measure the gio spits people know you
aren't fully tweeting develops it
gloomy in between and that's extreme al
die prodent how the date keep your
muscles set of showroom arn  him
ok so lets go and generic sample
chase little bit
knuckleheads it was you single never see an
ex we well please sex for binary
from also apply the night and day space
chemical sometimes there house rubicon was such a
man show that commercial house  for the
picture never and me and offers do not use
jos de tour wax is ex your chair computer
by what we can do just relax in a de ole
chappie doe
zo is catchy and first example'
is the cough ls bifuel sprite beatles this
is a  simple lessons have to do that
account for it so photo cross solution
i can still use the us do the trick you
don't have the goal is not here so had
mikey
so instead of having char won who switch
box
white with the php would be efficient very
simple pool  euro point 15
chirp td5
what of course this can be something
like so
interview will three will stan yes you
can see i query back i can see ya
budget and by free will strong and
de in axel i do you this way
is much better  than using the aud  io
package banish you who see variable so
do normal linear regression that then
three meters from you xyz carbon yeah right
in the snow video thumbtacks afterburner
in the furniture
what if you do or die ar den of crust
aim and something about the
de tribe of noise  net insight your ex'
so win you banish far wil this is not
go you never see fruit like me like an
explosion you can easily see it in views
dior art patch and who does is one thing
to top can see how you can calculate
the sec  mix of pyrite is a direct
relationship between two of them using
formula that do a show before
and with that i don't even say a thing
that do external types
sigma ex a check know why did you
look at the bottom you can see this
player can quickly quebec
work itself
ok you know critics db weiss fiber itself
and then how we about estimating and
wise the mirrors so i my ex is quite
large now n roll ie is
very pr
sigma ex europoint 457 views euro banger
this kind of europoint 1  5th she super d5 in
it bill bill bill oh very hot bang would
this sex oil amplify the effect of off
so over estimating the effect would
when playstations zoey implied
snares for
gios parents
actually doing linear
regression it's a little bit more
sophisticated asian rss  little can
our planet week rest and eating and
then i can also apply for crows french
with it would also be simple double machine
learning you can base injuries direction
courses simple when someone
flip the budget peace and in the hive
stupid chinese or something
but still a  leftover
or something can do it in building you can
input and missing data in it would
book such a thing or and how calm and with a nation
warburg a dashboard think you should
be careful is real cc one jim view
detail you can add some random most beautiful
dating more realistic what you
want to do now is the input the
fairmont lisbon you do in french
about peak if i do it double it's a
party bias fur  nishing remnants with
and then your really really there an extra
once this would
still what you shoot do with you as knee with
you can so much budget now in the puppies
in cell so there horemans
ns about wheels who is a paper with
you not wrong  almost everything is not possible
the presentation and that you come with
me and xlii is coming morphe the
object dissertation bias is about the us
of machine learning classification bald
and research for insider edition of
crust account fascination by
your mirrors the machine learning
base  texas the year noisy micro
abrasive and there are list of the
fermette put you can fry it including
all the bass and staff what i so one that
renewed but simple trick so to
email the professor got mail with one
that didn't reply that  waymarsh trick is
just too keep it simple to be able to
put into a paper 100 sharla dat when
spectacle verse
so rather recap
branch you be thinking about potentially
it is a party and
bias when you tap s  urf i might be on
server in your noisy ex
with you care about what happens to my
met the helm exchanges
and i can just
lease of the fight for my experience be
careful you don't need to worry if you
to blame productional classification
and ever  think about it ar you do
claim production of classification of
spain plan your mother to business unit
do in frans' set
it think they do that donates a party
corn in journal is good to think
about which er problem and the wheelie
challenge to beep from  business that
give us argument two wheel i tell you
about i have a debate glasses your water bottle
multi-modal so in chili ports 0 tony
citation bias eagles even supply the
family your soup model individually which
is to tell nation bias with us also
or form of  his voice
ok socials moltex tobias klein the
professor how supervised by almost ten
years ago
om the master thesis was almost such a big
little bit about remixing maize and vf
in supervising evil lo  t of jules en
serve since and that you a dior this
en koenraad is one of those students and
the well this thesis about you work for
mens would a wheelie work together om
gadding is de solution
en den ersten peper people you build
to colic menno  and
but with an omar rahou red pepper
we assign the seriousness oh house as a
women professor and him to me you
teach with mercury skuld westerbork the
replace at google the silence think
it's amazing detail
think that for it of producing the white
papers
so  tank
tanks tanks but that's very unique
ashens verhoeven
s
and xplay discussions of this I think him
so you mention you don't need
it
pioneers pi become sigma
so just be this juno and holder
measured
yes would chose lips nice title is
ok so the procession ink for the specific
jack sparrow in fight
so
wanting is you can explique to per whom
you will
from google apps which can be so if you
were searching on your phone fox ampel
actually use  your gps en to make use
more add event
zoë get some he forget two will and
ok
using gps how is in bridget a daze
in which a location
but then under website weekend you
also see a you clicked well dude now you
need under website  one in the widget level
cover
bbz and cut there would only be who
you would this one of hoe is the de can see
ok now i know and some information
about about how how noisy dissection is
de defense put through the measurement
of is hoe  who al is a mad lynde's
one
then a fine that libya problem rise
mirrors then i do people might be
more mobile with the family
it was me jekyll in dc and silent the
treatment moby ok white
of course if i look into the offline
store shell vote in  that a deadline
she des borneo is there in these websites
it is you already 6 ohm information the
goals ben
wie epsom information ok
returning visitor wash in want
province bank times and time and then
in the anders wrote is also such a churning
of o  verlap
table most clean and this makes it
possible to ever pay attention to meer de wil more
sophisticated eta will je connects the
computer peak value for heavy provinc
which assisten polen mobility ok this
such at the switch to het rieten wieg
in arnhem twitter twitch en  vice versa
so this is yes little bit and it is not
the perfect solution with the singles
such a gotcha most metro phonology dies
accessart
in you have the human race